recently the government passed
legislation allowing each council to
adopt local policy permitting easter
sunday trading in their district to help
our council decide what to do in our
district we want to hear what you think
the question is simple do you support
shops opening for trading on Easter
Sunday do you think we have businesses
should be given the option open on
easter sunday not yes i think people
could be given a choice i think if
somebody has their own business and they
want the open letters together closely
hmm ok sphere sacred day you know if
you're not as a fun Christmas now
they've been I was glad to open good
friday you should be my present for me
yeah touch you or no maintenance Oh
modern times there isn't it will change
yes place a personal choice I think I
should leave at this moment and just
have it as public 10 nov everybody gets
Holliday they have an opinion yeah i
just lost so you've heard what they have
to say what do you think let's talk you
can make your feedback 9 on our website
facebook or at any of our service
centers easter trading is just one topic
covered in a draft and your plan visit
Waimakariri govt gon get to find out
more and have your say
Oh
[Music]